c'est ainsi que marie claire à tailler
un costard de haute couture à quelques
jolis minois qui graviront en bas
dentelle les marches de l'assemblée pour
aller représenter les femmes le rpr
présente les modèles ouistiti sexe
modèle tonique tout à fait dans la ligne
marine fluctuat nec mergitur coupe de
cheveux patriotique à la jeanne d'arc se
portent avec des lunettes pour voir loin
création du pc rayures rouges et
blanches tout climat chaud d'à côté
frais de l'autre boutonnet est ouest
mais de préférence à gauche
longueur 1 10e modèle en train d'
humanité le ps propose quelque chose de
rose bien sûr très allants mettrait sur
un esprit junior pour de crocodile ne
craignant pas les accros encore du ps le
modèle le plus coté au sondage près du
corps tonique ni femme femme ni lui ni
sexe ni rigide n'exprimant pas le mois
le bonheur va
morisien les sans parti nous offre une
collection bien assise pour celles qui
veulent être élégantes sans pour autant
se priver de tout modèle raisonnable
impression dissidente couleurs
contrastées c'est une robe qu'ils
cohabitent pas les stylistes de l'idf
travaille dans le bon chic bon genre
modèle trait à sa place en toutes
occasions mariages baptêmes élections le
modèle peut se porter avec ou sans veste
ça dépendra du temps qu'il fera
vers la mi mars